tabloid reports always are saying Ellen
and Portia are breaking up I I look for
signs about the janitor at the jennifer
aniston wedding yeah I was looking for
signs of a crack relationship yeah you
must a fight in public appeared in front
of me any very much in love but it does
that bother you do the two of you get
upset about that we don't know anything
about it until somebody tells us because
I don't I don't have a publicist and I
don't don't read those read I don't read
the tabloids and I don't have a
publicist so until until someone calls
and recently Porsha's publicist called
and said we really should sue because
now they're they're doing this again and
they were like following us for a week
because I had a week off and and I was
doing different things in her so they
for sure there's very separate
yeah it was like I went to a condo that
we owned with my best friend and they
said that I was going to my love nest
with and having an affair with my best
friend Victoria anyway I don't
understand why they do it because and
we're kind of flattered because for a
while no one cared about us and we
thought oh lesbians aren't you know
worthy of tabloid stories so now we're
kind of flattered that we even cared
they care about us but we we really
don't almost break up we don't fight we
are madly in love and I guess it's
borings are good but things are
fantastic and because the both of you
were in show business is there a lot of
personal jealousy when she goes off to
her said do you get nervous that she's
gonna meet somebody and that does she
get because I imagine a lot of women
come on to you quite frankly I know
nobody gets jealous
no one gets jealous how do you avoid
that I I just had to have faith and that
we love each other there's not one bit
of doubt that she's not I mean like
literally yesterday she said you're my
everything and I said I literally was
just thinking that last I was laying
awake going she's my everything like we
think the same things we're so similar
and yet we're different enough there is
nothing more romantic than what you just
said I think